I think that uh um Will Smith smacking
Chris Rock was staged really
really what do you guys think I don't
know yeah I have no clue I almost don't
care you almost died I don't I I don't
care at all uh about you know that event
that took place but I think it's
important to talk about uh mental health
and you know Mike cernovich has been on
top of this talking about how uh you
know it's probably taking a toll on will
the fact that you know he allows his
wife to sleep with other men and then
you know he's totally okay with that but
a joke uh he he gets upset by and so
Will's probably not all there right now
uh from a mental health standpoint and
so even I I could see how it wouldn't be
stage I could see how uh maybe he just
had enough and he had a snap someone did
Super Chat as saying trust me it wasn't
staged and the way Chris Rock reacted
there's two things one suggests it was
stage one that it wasn't after he got
hit you could tell that he didn't know
what to do and he was like in a
difficult position where he was like uh
uh and they said we're giving away
documentaries Oscars because he's
clearly flushed he got smacked in the
face however
when Will Smith cranks up to hit him
Chris Rock doesn't put his hands up
which is a common reflex when you're
about to be hit yeah in fact he does a
maybe it was an accident but he makes a
move that is common in fight
choreography where he moves with the
hand swing yeah so when someone is fake
slapping you what you do is when the
hand is coming in you move with it so
it's a glancing hit and less impact to
your face well their ratings have been
in the tank for the last few years and
nobody talks about them anymore and now
everybody's talking about it today
there's been great memes created already
it's a great meme template Will Smith is
a you know he's I'm very grateful for
his work and giving us good meme
templates over the years
um his movies have been lackluster to
say the least as of late but he gives us
great meme templates and so there's a
lot you can do with the slap
cuck was trending on Twitter all day
really because Jada Pinkett Smith
apparently is allowed to be with anybody
she wants yeah I gotta read Mike
cernovich's tweet it was the best tweet
I saw on this whole uh situation Mike's
Brown fire for this he's always on fire
he he tweeted being a cuck just went out
of style everyone saw a broken man
trying to save face don't be smacking
cheeks when you letting other men
clapping cheeks wow poetic by cerno and
it's almost 10 000 likes on that one oh
man
um Twitter doesn't let me pull this
stuff up anymore but so so look you know
I I didn't study Hollywood Bakery in law
school so I don't pretend to be an
expert but you know I would say as a as
a layperson I don't I don't buy this I
think it's about as real as you know
wardrobe malfunctions right in the past
uh you know and and look there you know
Hollywood is uh expert in uh staging
things right that's what they do for a
living yeah and and so and that's why
the cops didn't come in look and I'm a
I'm a fan of uh Will Smith he's a fellow
Philadelphian
um so uh you know uh I you know I I
think that the whole thing smells and it
and and it's the kind of thing you
launch when you're in an uh awards show
that no one wants to watch anymore yeah
it's possible it was real yeah like you
know you can think about the LAPD said
you know Chris Rock's not not gonna file
so that's it my response is the police
don't need the victim to file if the
police have evidence enough enough to
convict they can go on whether or not
you you as a victim want them to so it
could just be it's all one big happy
family and they're like we don't want
cops arresting Will Smith just let it go
and they all say Let It Go and that's
what happens when you're powerful
wealthy Elites you can walk up to him
and smack him in the face for your
wife's honor and you're not going to
spend it you're not you're going to go
party afterwards and get drunk yeah I
personally thought uh the clip of Amy
Schumer and her her fellow idiots
singing gay on the stage was uh I didn't
watch it uh you got you got to pull that
one up you literally have Amy Schumer
and two people I've never seen or heard
of it before my entire life singing you
know protesting around to Santos's Bill
saying gay gay it's just so weird that
Hollywood would be protesting like the
most milk toast attempt at an
anti-grooming Bell strange but I mean
Roman Polanski is yeah you're just
jealous again going back to your
detention slip yeah I'm I'm seriously
pissed where was Amy Schumer when I got
sent to the princess that's exactly
right that's exactly right
Hollywood's dead man yeah they had uh 10
million total viewers in the Oscars last
year brutal and that was down like 60
from the year before yeah we did a
cartoon about that if you guys want to
check out it's called the Locust Oscars
on freedom tins I'm not sure if it was
stage I said I almost don't care I guess
it may be some small part of me does a
little bit just because I very much
dislike Hollywood and they do something
ridiculous and I want to say uh
darn Hollywood but
whether it was faked or not
it's clear that this has had the effect
of people ridiculing a specific person
at the Oscars rather than the entire
ceremony as a whole because for the past
couple years it's been how unbelievably
stupid is this ridiculous padding of
oneself on the back ceremony that occurs
where they give Awards to their friends
for doing things that they sit there and
pretend uh is important while the rest
of us don't really care Sheamus yeah I
would like to award you oh my gosh our
first annual Cassie Tim I just oh my God
that's beautiful so I want to say that
we have always been ahead of the curve
on Tim casting
in telling ordinary Americans that
they're wrong and need to be more like
us thank you for this award yo legit I
think I'm gonna buy a bunch of those
little alpacas yeah give them out as
Awards yeah I think I should go pick
some up Sheamus didn't say he stands
with Ukraine in his speech so yeah
come on give it back yeah we're gonna
cancel Sheamus he gave it back it's mine
again oh
I think it is
the crane that's right
right like an award turn around on him
doesn't need to be said exactly it goes
without saying if we did like an award
ceremony called the truth ease or
something and we use little alpacas yes
do you think you think James O'Keefe
would mind that'd be so good James is
great so this is what if you what if it
was an award ceremony for like most
contrived speech and we just went to
different podcasters and awarded them
based on who gave a really contrived
speech at some point in their podcast
and then they have to give a contrived
speech while they're up on stage
receiving it I mean who who would be
better for that is that the whole point
of the award show someone goes on stage
gives a contrived speech a lot of people
get mad at it it boosts ratings and
people pay attention wouldn't it make
more sense to just cut out the nonsense
and give people awards simply for making
contrived numbers it is a crazy thought
when you realize that nobody watches the
Oscars these great cultural moments
losing significance and now we just
don't care anymore we're talking about
it now because some dude smacked another
dude but whether it was staged or not
that's the only thing they have that
makes us talk about it yeah do you know
do you know what movie Will Smith was in
no
yes it is but my point is people don't
even know what movie Will Smith was in
when he was there and all they know is
on TV some guy smacked another guy
that's all the Oscars is these days yeah
but you know the back to the uh I'm
becoming probability guy uh you know
back to the combining probabilities
right the fact that uh the show is
failing and the only thing that makes
anyone talk about it is this incident to
me suggests that the incident is
artificial right
makes sense it's fake news
fake news but uh people need to
understand too that that stage doesn't
mean anybody other than Will Smith and
Chris Rock knew about it it could even
be that that Chris Rock didn't know
about it but Will Smith's people told
him this would be really good for
publicity because we you know we heard
he's going to tell a joke go up there
and smash is he gonna get like an
alopecia like anti-alipia contract I
don't know we're talking about it's his
first Oscar isn't it it's the first one
he's ever won I don't know that is I
don't know also what was the joke even
G.I Jane like why is that a bad joke
because Jada Pinkett Smith has alopecia
so her hair's falling out so she shaved
her head
so he was like I look forward to GI Jane
too and Will Smith laughed and then Jada
Pinkett Smith's face like glared at him
and then she looks at him and then he
gets up and then you know Chris Rock
Says something like oh hey Richard or
whatever and then Will Smith slaps him I
thought it was fake I thought it was
fake because the cops didn't come I
thought it was fake because Chris Rock
didn't do anything
that's the weirdest thing to me
I I don't know if I was on stage and
someone walked up to me the first thing
I would do is be like I put my hand up
and be like back off what are you doing
yeah I don't come to me like this I
don't know though man because if if we
were gonna fake a fight and that was our
whole thing and
you were supposed to come up and smack
me I wouldn't be like yes I'm gonna take
the role of the guy who stands there in
front of the entire world and doesn't
fight back after he got smacked in the
face it just seems like a really weird
thing to agree to I saw all these
comments
defending his wife's honor and uh who
defends their wife signing with us like
an open hand slap I gotta be honest I
think it's good that we're talking about
it do you yeah because I'd rather people
of low
um what's the right what's the what's
the polite way to say this of low
cognitive of limited cognitive faculties
I would prefer it if they weren't coming
out and arguing politics and voting for
Biden you know the way I put it is when
I was younger I was like I wish more
people were involved in politics why
don't they pay attention all they care
about is sports and celebrities then
2020 happens and all people cared about
was politics but they didn't know
anything about it and so they're like I
just feel like we're in a car you know
we're in a bus and everyone's like we
can drive off the cliff or just turn
around and I'm like I vote to turn
around and they're like off the cliff
off I'm like no no everybody look at the
rabbit look out the window look at the
rabbit stop if people want to pay
attention to politics and they're
passionate about it then by all means we
can have disagreements for whoever we
want but if regular people are going
like yo he smacked that guy I'd rather
have them be more interested in that
than going out and voting on things they
don't know about and aren't interested
in you don't got to be smart to vote I'm
not saying that I'm saying if you don't
care about it and you're only going out
and voting because pop culture that's a
problem let's have everybody go watch
sports and pop culture somewhere else
and anybody of any intellect or you know
whatever you're allowed to vote so long
as you want to and you're choosing to
take that first step right you're saying
it consumes their attention span uh you
know budget and I guess I gotta thank
will and Chris because they were able to
shift the new cycle away from Ukraine
for a very short moment and so I just
now we're back I just wonder if Will
Smith has some Irish in his blood
that's a great point that that must be
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there